hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar Chicago and dovetail
high C yield chromosome link scaffolds
of the exodia scapularis genome I am
Judy O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you like dovetailed
genomics dovetail genomics is
transforming genomics by making
long-range genomic information readily
accessible to all the company enables
researchers and clinicians to solve
complex problems involving de novo
assembly structural variation cancer
research and more by providing a
comprehensive view of the genome for
more information on our sponsor please
visit does Cal genomics comm let's get
started you can post questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind
to do so simply type them into the drop
down box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
on the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab found at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen I now present
today's speakers Monica gulia nos PhD
assistant professor in the department of
biochemistry and molecular biology at
the University of Nevada Reno and Marc
Daly Marc Daly is the director of
business development and has been with
dovetail for two years dr. Gillian
nurses research focuses on understanding
the basic biology of kicks to identify
novel targets for tick control her long
term goal is to develop novel strategies
to control ticks and take borne disease
transmission to this end
she's generating first-ever transgenic
kicks using the crisper cast gene
editing system and employing other
cutting-edge genomic techniques
these include high sea-based genome
scaffolding for better assembly and
annotation of the TIC genome her work
focuses on understanding the role of
insulin signaling and kick pathogen
interactions and differences in the
chemo reception circuit in different
exodia's species her complete bio is on
the labyrinth website dr. ghoulia nuts
will now begin her presentation
great so thankful
for the introduction my name is Mark
Dailey and I'm the director of business
development here at dovetail I've been
with a company for about two-and-a-half
years and I'm very privileged to to be a
part of Monica's presentation today I
think it's going to be really exciting
before Monica gets started on her slides
though I just want to give everybody a
brief 10 or 15-minute overview on the
dovetail technology just so it kind of
sets the stage for for Monica my email
is here on the first slide so if you do
want to reach out to me with any
questions I also have a much longer
version of my slides that I'm happy to
present one-on-one with anybody in the
audience just send me an email I'd be
happy to do that
so dovetail you know all we do is de
novo assembly we've been doing it now
for over five years and we're
specialists in de novo assembly and
we've now done over a thousand de Novo's
most of those for actual customers we've
done quite a few internal projects as
well so we've really got a lot of
experience in doing this and what I'm
going to do is take you through the
process of building a de novo assembly
at dovetail this first slide serves kind
of as a primer for de novo assembly I'm
sure there's people on the line here
that are new to de novo and I want to
make sure that everybody you know
understands this information so I'm
going to explain some of the terminology
as I go along this slide also summarizes
what dovetail does in a single so we we
in order to build a good quality highly
accurate highly contiguous de novo
assembly we need to understand that we
need to capture the genome on different
scales and on the left side of this
slide I've listed the three scales of
genomic content short range mid range
and long range and we go through this
process in a stepwise fashion to build
greater and greater contiguity until we
get to a
point where each chromosome is
represented with a single scaffold and a
common terminology that you'll see in
this presentation is the scaffold in 50
and just for folks that are new to de
novo assembly the scaffold in 50 is
really the standard way of measuring
quality of a de novo it really
represents in simplistic terms the
median scaffold size of the assembly so
the lower the the higher the m50 number
the better and and so what I've shown
here is this progression of capturing
greater and greater contiguity the
initial short-range data is typically
what would be represented in a draft
assembly so we can either take a draft
assembly from you and improve it or we
can build one entirely from scratch here
at dovetail but in either case the draft
assembly is typically built using a
variety of methods one or a combination
of the lumina short read technology
shown on the left
PacBio long range technology or long
read technology shown in orange there
10x genomics is a newer technology that
we're starting to use at dovetail that
is a synthetic long read technology
there's also Oxford nanopore which is a
newer long read technology as well and
we will choose the appropriate
technology based on our knowledge of the
organism that you're working with so but
it's really about selecting the right
tool for the job and at in any case
however we build that initial draft
assembly we'll get it to a point where
we can then apply a mid-range data type
which in our case is called Chicago and
Chicago reads are shown in red there and
Chicago reads are kind of like really
big mate pair reads they can span
genomic content from between around a
kilobase up to about 150 kilobases so
we're starting to capture a much greater
scale of genomic content and as you can
see in like in my graphic here we're
starting to make joins between contexts
that are quite distant from each other
so now we're starting to build Scout
holes which are shown in purple here but
we're still far from chromosomes scale
so we need to employ a third technology
to capture the long-range data which in
our case is called dovetail hi-c and
those reads are shown in black there and
dovetail hi-c is a very unique
technology and that we can create mega
base sized reads so we can literally
span one telomere to the other and
ultimately get you up to chromosomes
scale assembly and that's really the
ultimate goal of someone that is
building a de novo you want to really
get to a point where each chromosome is
represented with a single scaffold and
that's what we're able to do at dovetail
we often use this final step called
gap-filling which is taking low coverage
PacBio reads and essentially filling in
gaps where we're able to after the high
c step so at the end of this whole
process you'll get an assembly that is
not only highly contiguous but also very
accurate
we employ a variety of different de novo
techniques to get that initial draft
assembly and I've listed them here the
most common ones are Illumina short read
technology which is the least expensive
and it's also very widespread but the
caveat there is short read technology is
really only good for easy genomes
quote-unquote and easy genomes are
typically birds mammals and haploids
if you're not working with one of those
then you really need to bring in some
kind of long read technology which could
be 10x genomics PacBio Oxford nanopore
are the most common ones and I've listed
the advantages and disadvantages of each
of those and again if we're building
this assembly at dovetail we'll make
sure we consult with you on choosing the
best approach for your budget and for
the level of complexity of the assembly
that you have
okay so now we've built this initial
draft assembly so now we can start
scaffolding it to full chromosomes and
this is where we start using the
proprietary dovetail technology and we
have three major types of libraries that
we work with a dovetail for scaffolding
they're listed here in this cartoon
Chicago 6e and high C dovetail high C
now fixie is a very specific technology
that's really only used for
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded human
tumor samples so I'm not going to talk
about that here today if anyone on the
call is interested in hearing about that
to send me an email for now I'm going to
focus on Chicago and dovetail high C so
these two technologies share basically
the same molecular biology steps Chicago
starts with purified high molecular
weight DNA whereas high C starts with
tissue so I'll start with Chicago what
we do with Chicago's we extract
ultra-high purity molecular weight
ultra-high molecular DNA typically
around 150 KB long and what we do and so
what I've shown here in the cartoon you
can think of this as 150 KB molecule
here and I'm following two points on
this molecule labeled 1 & 2 through this
whole process so you can see what
happens the first thing we do in Chicago
is we strip off all the protein from the
DNA and so we're removing all the
chromatin and then what we do is we
build artificial chromatin in vitro and
the blue circles represent artificial
nucleosomes and there's a very important
reason why we do this first step which
is that natural chromatin for example
like you would use in in high c likes to
form looping structures and those
looping structures while they may be of
interest biologically they will actually
create proximity ligation events that
are
due to biology and not due strictly to
linear distance along the along the
molecule and those biological events
will create a lot of background noise
that make scaffolding much more
difficult so the beauty about Chicago
data is that it's very clean data and
I'm going to show you that in a few
minutes I'll show an example of that so
we've created this artificial chromatin
we then add formalin which does two
things it condenses that molecule down
into a globular molecule bringing
distant parts of the molecule close
together so you can now see one and two
are very close together where they used
to be very far apart it also creates
covalent cross-linking the protein shown
in red there and fixes that molecule in
space in step B what we do is we chop up
that molecule with an endonuclease
creating sticky ends in step C we blunt
fill those sticky ends and add a biotin
label which is just used for a
downstream purification step and then in
step D that's what I like to call the
magic step because we actually add a
ligase which then randomly ligates those
blunt ends together and essentially
you're going to get every possible
representation of a ligation event for
each of these molecules in this case you
can see that one and two that used to be
very far apart are now literally joined
together and that's going to be very
valuable
long-range proximity data that we're
going to be able to utilize in step e we
release those cross links and now we
have all of these proximity events
floating around in solution you can see
that in our example here two of these
proximity events are of real interest to
us the top and bottom because those two
represent internal ligation events the
middle one is not of interest because no
internal event occurred so we'll just
ignore that middle one but we're going
to then take the
internally ligated events and sequence
them with traditional Illumina p150
pyridine 150 sequencing and we're going
to take all of those proximity sequence
events and put them into our high-rise
software and high-rise we'll take your
draft assembly and the chicago data and
it'll attempt to make long-range
connections utilizing that proximity
data and so now we're starting to build
contiguity in this assembly Delta hi-c
does a very similar the the process is
very similar except we're starting with
tissue instead of DNA and so you can
imagine that in step a there instead of
this being a single molecule this is
actually an entire chromosome and so
this process of proximity ligation
occurs throughout the entire chromosome
for one end to the other and thus when
we take that data and put it into
high-rise we're now going to start
building continuity up to a full
chromosome so let's now take a look at
the data that comes off these two
different libraries quickly so this
first slide showing the data shows on
the x-axis the genomic coordinates
notice the two scales are different this
first chart goes out to half a mega base
the right-hand chart goes out to a
hundred mega bases the vertical axis is
the same in both charts it's the
proportion of proximity events of a
certain size so the chicago data is
charted in green and if we go to the
very top of the chicago curve
these are proximity events that are a
few kilobases apart as we go down this
curve the events get farther and farther
apart until we get to the very bottom
here and this represents the longest
molecule in the sample so these are
proximity events that are around 150
kilobases apart so in chicago data we
have this very deep coverage of the
genome between 1 kb and 150 kb
the dovetail hi-c chart or or curve is
totally different
it's much flatter and goes out well
beyond half a mega base in fact we have
to zoom out to the right hand chart to
see that dovetail hi-c data actually
goes out to the end of the chromosome so
you get this incredible coverage
covering the entire chromosome and very
even covering these these curves are
very reproducible from organism to
organism you can see that on the right
chart the scale is so great that the
chicago data is barely visible so one
might ask then well if hi-c data is
giving me full chromosome scale
contiguity or coverage what why do I
need Chicago data what's the point of
having Chicago data if IC is giving me
full chromosomes and there's two very
important benefits of chicago data that
i'm now going to talk about the first
big benefit of chicago data is that it
boosts your input assembly contiguity to
a point where high c will effectively
work it turns out that in all our
experience of doing this hundreds and
hundreds of times that IC really
requires an input and fifty close to a
mega base to work effectively and in
this example which is a weeping
lovegrass which is a 600 mega base
genome you can see that on the top table
the input assembly had an N 50 of 380 KB
0.38 mega bases when we applied I see
only to that assembly we only improve
the contiguity to about 5 mega bases
this is far short of chromosome scale so
this was really a failure right we did
not assemble contiguity level
sorry chromosome level contiguity in
this assembly what we did then as we did
Chicago first so we took that input
assembly and applied chicago data to it
boosting the contiguity to closer to a
mega base
Oh point seven nine one megabases and
then we took that assembly and ran it
through our hi-c process that's when we
achieved chromosome scale continuity as
shown in the very bottom table
we got a continuity of 45 mega bases
that was chromosome scale so Chicago
data is needed as a mid-range step in
between your input assembly and the hi-c
assembly
second major advantage of Chicago is in
accuracy so now I'm going to shift gears
from talking about contiguity to talking
about accuracy because there's no point
in building a very highly contiguous
assembly if it's full of miss joins and
errors what I'm showing here now is a
comparison of the same region of a
genome using Chicago data on the left
and hi-c data on the right the vertical
axis is the size of the proximity event
going from one KB at the bottom up to
200 KB at the top the very first thing
you notice is that Chicago data has far
higher density than high C data each
purple dot that I've shown there is a is
a proximity event this makes sense
because with high C we're trying to
assemble we're trying to scaffold entire
chromosomes whereas with Chicago we're
only having to assemble molecules of 100
or 150 Kb so this data density
difference makes a lot of sense so what
we then did is we introduced a false
miss joint into the input assembly and
then tried to scaffold that with Chicago
and IC and the miss joint is is actually
an immersion event that we purposely
created and it's shown in red here and
when high-rise sees this data it's not
able to properly position the Chicago
reads
because of the false miss joint so those
reads get displaced and the data gets
displaced in this bowtie pattern that I
circled here these signatures they stand
out like a sore thumb
they're very diagnostic of a false miss
joint or a miss joint you notice that in
the hi-c data in the same region of the
genome there's no difference between the
top and bottom plots in other words hi-c
data is not able to enable it's not able
to to allow high-rise to find these miss
joints the reason why is that it's not
it doesn't have a high enough density so
what Chicago is providing you with your
assembly is not only boosting contiguity
but it's also allowing high rise to
identify and correct false miss joins in
the input assembly thus giving you a far
more accurate final assembly than if you
did not use Chicago data
the next slide shows you that what the
raw data looks like comparing Chicago on
the right to hi-c on the left you can
see that the hi-c data is very noisy
those squares that I've shown with
arrows represent tad domains those are
the looping structures that form in
natural chromatin again very interesting
to a biologist but they really confound
de novo assembly but data on the right
is extremely clean and that is why
Chicago data is so powerful in allowing
us to properly order and orient context
in your input assembly and correct miss
joint events
I'm almost done with my slides here just
a couple more this slide shows you the
progression of de novo assembly going
from the input de novo on the Left where
we have tens of thousands of scaffolds
that lie along the diagonal here the the
midpoint which is Chicago we're now
starting to build mega base ice scalpels
shown in dark blue those squares along
the diagonal but we still have lots and
lots of smaller scalpels so we're not
nearly at chromosome scale but we're
building up the contiguity then on the
far right when we add in the hot dog
tail high C data we finally get single
scaffolds for each chromosome
represented
we've done like I said hundreds and
hundreds of Assemblies of all kinds of
taxa mammals reptiles plants fish
insects we've done polyploids highly
heterozygous assemblies and this slide
kind of just shows you a brief sort of
cross-section of some of the genomes
we've done and I'm showing listed to
just basically demonstrate that
regardless of genome size regardless of
the input end 50 that we start with we
virtually always end up with chromosome
or near chromosome contiguity and you
can see the levels of improvement here
are pretty staggering in some of these
to 7,500 X improvement in continuity I
just want to end my presentation with
just a note on our new matching funds
award program work we're building this
tree of life which actually should go up
on our website pretty soon we're up to
around 350 organisms but we would love
to increase the size of our tree of life
you know with your genomes and so what
we're doing here is we're offering this
matching funds award you can apply at
the web site here or send me an email
and I'll make sure that your application
gets entered and you know that the
purpose of this is really to help offset
the cost of de novo assembly we'd love
to get to a point where every organism
on the planet has been sequenced and
we'd love to be a part of that so if
you're interested in applying to this
award program just let me know so with
that I appreciate your or listening to
my slides and my presentation with that
I will pass it over to Monika and she
will present her tick assembly project
that she did with us
thank you Mark for very informative
overview of the technique I would also
take this opportunity to thank dr.
genomics for funding this project and
doing an incredible job at it
the this project as a part of the bigger
project that we have been working on
sequencing the genome so I'm a vector
biologist an assistant professor at the
Department of Biochemistry and molecular
biology at University of Nevada in Reno
my lab is interested in understanding
arthropod biology in general we are also
very interested in arthropod pathogen
interactions and identifying novel
targets for disease vector controls one
of the major area of research in my lab
is to develop new molecular tools for
tick research and I will talk about the
genome assembly here today I was very
fortunate fortunate to be part of the
tick genome consortium and was the first
author on the publish to the genome
paper this tick genome that we published
in 2016 was a decade worth of work and
the sequencing was sequencing took place
pretty next-gen sequencing era so that
was really not an easy feat to because
it's a complex genome and I will talk
about that during my my presentation
here so I have a this presentation today
I have I will talk about tick lifecycle
first and then I'll talk about the
importance of studying tick vectors and
then I will give you a little background
of tick genome the first assembly is
good one
this is I scapularis wykel strain one
assembly then I will talk about need for
a new assembly and Chicago and dovetail
hi-c assembly that till we just did with
the duck tail genomics and what the next
steps are in this process and then I
will be happy to take any questions
later
the our main objective for doing this
project or carrying out this project was
to obtain a chromosomal level scaffold
assembly for a highly reputable genome I
we really wanted to improve the
annotation using highly contiguous
genome and as Mark mentioned that with
the hi-c you can get highly contagious
genome and this is what probably
everybody needs for their genome we
wanted to improve the internal analysis
because right now our genome is quite
fragmented and I will talk about that in
a bit
the first I would like to talk about the
ticks are our model organism the to tick
that we work on is black legged tech or
exotic scapularis it's a very important
vector of Lyme disease tricks have one
to two years life cycle especially and I
should say the black legged kick has one
to two year of life cycle depending on
where they are the geographical area in
Northeast where it's a colder life cycle
is usually two years in Southeast and in
Pacific West it's usually a year of life
cycle each life stage of tech requires
over the bridge blood meal so that means
when the chicks hatch from eggs into
larvae require a blood meal and then
they molt influence and limbs require
blood meal to further mold into adults
then males of this species do not feed
whereas the female feed in a to
reproduce so here you can see that there
are multiple time points in their life
cycle when they can acquire a pathogen
and transmit this pathogen to the next
organism when they are feeding on that
organism most infections most bacterial
infections in particular our interest
area that means they carry over from one
stage to another stage after molting for
example if a kick larvae get infected
that the resulting nymph will be
infected as well
so why are we studying tick vectors well
as I said tick vectors are quite
important hard to X or X DX OD day group
these are vectors for rickettsial
spirochete or viral bacterial protozoan
diseases tech causes or tech carries the
pathogens for more diseases than any
other organism they can also not only
the pathogens that they can also lead to
severe toxic conditions for example
paralysis and toxicosis Lyme disease
itself in fact more than 300,000
individuals every year in the United
States and Lyme disease is the fastest
growing vector borne infectious disease
in the United States so there is a
there's a big need for understanding
these two vectors and when we are trying
to understand these vectors one of the
areas that we are lacking is the
availability of a good genome
so this is the first assembly 15 the
iske w1 assembly that was published in
2016 and this is the only tech species
that has been sequenced to date so
Exodia scapularis the problematic
genomes is they're quite large for
example Exodia scapularis genome is 2.1
eg base pairs and another complexity
that they add is there's our highly
repetitive genome the the sequencing
that we carried out the sequence that
was published earlier in 2016 was done
VESA with backs and back in sequencing
which resulted in three point eight fold
coverage but it was a highly fragmented
genome as I mentioned I was fragmented
into two 370,000 scaffolds approximately
and m50 of the scaffold was
approximately 50 flow base pair over
20,000 protein coding genes were
identified in in the genome i scapularis
preliminary fish-based karyotype
resulted or predicted chromosome number
2n equals 28 so 28 chromosomes they have
x and y chromosomes as well so this
s-curve an assembly was served was good
done with the embryos of Michael strain
and that's where the W comes from the
win and as I said that this family was
highly segmented for 370,000 test
scaffolds this highly fragmented
assembly makes it really difficult to do
any transcriptome assemblies so most of
the transcriptome assemblies that have
been done on checks on it on any of
these ELISA species have been DeNoble
assemblies because the existing genome
is the fragments it's too fragmented
to confidently align these transcripts
to the genome
and this also makes its fighter it also
complicates the Auto love identification
because the genomes are quite fragmented
and the gene models are incomplete the
good genes internet' and fifty needs to
be higher approximately 1 mb or higher
as good for genes Antonia analysis so a
highly contagious genome was needed for
correct gene annotation and sentiment
analysis so that's where we contacted
the Chicago a definitely contacted the
scale genomics to carry out Chicago
industrial high C assembly and we were
fortunate to get this project funded
through matching grant
but this is I'm not going to go over the
details of Chicago and dovetail Heise
because the mark already gave a very
good overview of pieces how these
techniques work so what we got from
dovetail genomics was so when they sent
us the results these results were
incredible here you can see that our 50
and 50 of the FDA hydride assembly
resulted in 12 scaffolds that were 40 48
MB pea soup out of and and there were
several a lot of scaffolds were over 1
MB so these are their biggest is their
largest scaffolds here listed almighty L
90 and 90 resulted in 2895 scaffolds of
four point zero two three zero mV
so here if we look at this graph this is
a comparison of the contiguous of input
assembly and high-rises scaffolds each
curve here shows the fraction of the
total length of assembly that's present
in a scaffold of a given length or
smaller and the fraction of the assembly
is indicated on the y axis here and
scaffold length in base pair is on the x
axis these two dashed line here
represent L and 50 and 90 lengths each
so any scaffold that was less than 1 KB
was excluded from this analysis so these
are all over 1k be careful here if we
look at this link density hence the
histogram you will you'll see that here
the all the scaffolds that were less
than one ambi were excluded from the
analysis the x-axis and y-axis are
mapping positions of the first and
second read in the lead pair
respectively
these are grouped into bins the color of
each square gives the number of reads
pair within that bin
white vertical line and black horizontal
lines have been added to show the the
borders of this of the scaffolds and as
I said all the scaffolds less than 1mb
were deleted from or but taken out from
this analysis
- this this link when we looked at these
disk apples these long scaffolds there
were 28 long scaffolds those were over
one an MD D bed and this 20 and number
28 corresponds to the chromosome number
so which is gifts that we have
chromosome level assembly of the genome
here
so here if we compare this assembly
statuses with the original escalators as
this is amazing here too to see that we
went from three approximately 370,000 to
scaffolds that were over 1 KB to 80 2672
scaffolds with high-rise assembly there
were the kinetic and 50 bus 2.94 KB in
original assembly which improved to 64
point to 1 KB in highlights assembly and
then we have the percent gaps in present
genome in the gap words approximately 49
percent without assembly and so we have
only real 51 percent of genome was
sequenced here with the high-rise
assembly we have approximately 3 percent
of the genome that's in gaps this is a
remarkable feat to to achieve and this
now gives us hope to improve our
annotation well so the key takeaway from
this presentation or this project is
that dovetail highlights assembly can
give you very high scaffolds very very
long scaffold so we our analysis or our
data resulted in 12 scaffolds of over 48
MB there were 20 scaffolds that were
over 1 MB and this number corresponds to
the number of chromosomes in tip genome
the genome synteny as I said requires
the scaffolds of over one MVP and we are
in a good shape now to do this internal
analysis and hopefully we will have a
very good annotated genome so successful
contiguous chromosome level assembly is
a highly repetitive genome was possible
because of this technique
the major key takeaway from here is that
because we have now this ability to
rapidly and reliably reliably to
generate genome assemblies that come
from lengths scaffolds for non-model
organisms this would accelerate genome
analysis of many organisms and that
includes other tick species as well not
only exuded but we might be able to now
get come from land scaffolds and
assemblies for even better tick genomes
such as syphilis Micropolis that genome
is is approximately 7m and GBP so this
gives us a lot of hope so what's the
next step for us for we would like to
fill the gaps
now either with connects genomics or
PacBio since we have very few gaps our
genome is about 3 percent of genome as
in as in gaps probably 10x genomics will
be an inexpensive option for us to fill
those gaps and then reassemble the
genome
hopefully with highlight scaffolds with
the dovetail genomics again we will once
we have this contiguous genome we would
like to map our existing gene models to
the new assembly and hopefully we will
have a full 90 genes available
and with this I am happy to take any
questions
thank you dr. googly enough for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. ghoulia knows will answer as many
questions as time permits the first
question is how should samples be
prepared before sending to dovetail
okay it's mark daily here I can take
that question so basically the most
important thing is that samples should
be flash-frozen
on liquid nitrogen and then shipped on
dry ice we do have a sample guidelines
document for both Chicago and dovetail
hi see that I can send anyone on the
call that's interested in getting that
just send me an email and I'll send that
to you but most important thing is being
proposed and we have tested a variety of
other sample prep methods like ethanol
and RNA later and lyophilized tissue and
they are kind of hit and miss they don't
always necessarily get high quality DNA
for Chicago so just use caution with
with those other kinds of sample prep
methods thank you next one is one sign
month please now I was just going to add
to that for our samples and I agree with
mark fresh frozen samples worked great
for most anything that we do in our lab
as well for our samples we sent three
different ways and six sample sets three
replicates of each because we didn't
know whether it will they will be able
to get good DNA amounts from adult ticks
or eggs so we sent both the egg clutches
as well as text and the embryos were
used for these experiments we are quite
fortunate that ticks lay a lot of eggs
so they lay about two to three thousand
eggs each female so we collected the
whole clutch of a female so there were
three different females that laid full
clutch and we sent three different sets
of samples flash frozen in liquid
nitrogen and sent on dry ice
yeah that's a good idea that's a really
good idea Monica to send more generally
more sample than we necessarily need we
can always send it back what we don't
want to do is like Monica said you know
we're in the middle we did we do an
extraction and for some reason it didn't
work and then we have to go back to you
to get more tissue and that you know
will delay the project so our project
managers will give you the specific
guidelines based on you know the kind of
organism you're working with thank you
thank you both next one is what if my
scaffold and 50 is less than the
recommended minimum of 20 KP
okay so in that case so we have this
minimum requirement to for an assembly
to go into Chicago that there it has to
be a fairly good quality assembly it
can't be too fragmented and our minimum
threshold for that is a scaffold and 60
of 20 KB or higher most of the projects
that we do where they're improving an
existing de novo assembly that our
client sends us most of our projects the
M 50s are higher than 20 but we have
occasionally got some that are lower
there's two options there either you can
risk running the scaffolding on your
more fragmented assembly we do have
examples and I think there was a slide
in this presentation of some projects
where the N 50 was lower than 20 I think
we did a the one of the turtle project
where it was I think 17 KB and it worked
really really well it's just that it's
not get you know as as likely to perform
and then if you had a higher end 50 so
the second option is that we would
recommend improving that input in 50 by
adding more sequence data to the draft
assembly so for example if you used
strictly Illumina sequencing for your
input assembly we might suggest using a
longer insert and doing more short
resequencing or even better adding some
long read sequencing like PacBio or 10x
genomics or Oxford nanopore as an
example to to get that initial end 50
above the 20 KB threshold at which time
then we can go into this chicago
pipeline
um one other quick thing is that I see
really requires an input and 50 of a
mega base or higher so the 20 KB metric
is strictly for Chicago if you're
attempting to do hi-c on an input
assembly with a scaffold in 50 lower
than a mega base it's not nearly as
likely to get you full chromosomes than
if your input end 50 was was a mega base
or higher
great thank you next one is what
challenges do you face when doing a new
project
mom I think so question yeah Mon okay
sure so like I think Monica addressed
one of the challenges already which is
you know with something as small as a
tick how do you minimize heterozygosity
and you know we for these for doing a
scaffolding project we need at least by
500 nanograms to a microgram of DNA for
the Chicago step and we also need
obviously tissue for the hi-c step and
you know Monica was saying that luckily
a single tick produces you know so many
eggs that we don't have too much of an
issue with that with her project but we
we have you know there's basically four
challenges at the draft de novo stage so
when we're building an assembly for our
clients the main challenges are
heterozygosity
genome size repeat content employee and
and those are things often we can't
control those right I mean the only
thing we can really potentially minimize
is heterozygosity
and we have various ways to
recommendations regarding that another
another kind of challenge is just sample
quality getting really good DNA high
molecular weight DNA for Chicago is
really critical to the final success of
scaffolding so if we're ideally we want
DNA that's around 150 kilobases long for
Chicago and if we're only able to
extract DNA that 75 kilobases
Chicago won't gaff hold as well
a final kind of main challenge that we
face is just if a client is sending us
an assembly to improve you know we don't
really have any control over the quality
of that assembly we will definitely QC
it and make sure that we believe it's
sufficient quality to scaffold but
having a good quality starting assembly
is also really important for final
success
thank you next one is how is high-rise
better than other scaffolding softwares
okay that's a great question so high
rise is a proprietary software platform
that was developed by Nick bought them
at dovetail and and the input data types
for high-rises either Chicago or
dovetail hi-c data we have there aren't
that many scaffolding software's out
there there's lots of de novo assemblers
in terms of we have done a direct
comparison with salsa - which is another
which is a publicly available
scaffolding software tool and we found
when we did a very controlled experiment
comparing high-rise with salsa - that
high-rise was more accurate it was it's
more conservative
we got fewer errors salsa - admittedly
deemed to provide a little bit higher
contiguity but high-rise was was more
accurate at the end and I have that data
if anyone is interested in in seeing
that experiment I can provide that the
other thing I want to emphasize too is
that dovetail is the only provider of
the Chicago service and that is a very
unique data type as we talked about in
the and the introductory slides in that
high-rise uses Chicago data to find and
correct miss joins in the input assembly
and that is a unique feature of
high-rise that makes that platform very
very powerful thank you the next
question is it does our draft assembly
need to be built in any particular way
before handing off to dovetail for
scaffolding
no so that so when if someone says of
the draft assembly to scaffold were
agnostic as to how that assembly is is
built as long as the minimum threshold
is Matt of 20 KB for Chicago and one
mega base n54 dovetail high C but
whether you use it doesn't matter what
kind of sequencing platform you use and
it also doesn't really matter what kind
of assembler you use what we like to
have though is the most accurate
draft assembly that you can provide us
and the more accurate and less
fragmented the input assembly is the
better Chicago and Delta high C will
just work that much more effectively
thank you the next question is if I
could only do one which is better
Chicago or dovetail hi-c
okay I can take that question so it
really depends on context starting
contiguity so if you only could do one
of those two methods if you're n 50 of
your input assembly is a less than a
mega base for example 100 KB or 200 KB
then I would highly recommend Chicago
because as I said I see ideally needs an
N 50 of a mega base to work effectively
if you have an input assembly where the
N 50 is very high like a mega base for
greater you'll probably get more bang
for your buck doing dovetail hi-c
thank you can i sequence your hi-c
elaborate library myself
yes you can definitely these libraries
are our standard Illumina libraries and
so you can sequence amana any of the
Illumina high-seat platforms we use the
high seek x10 when we do it
were you at dovetail as a service but
certainly we can ship the libraries to
you and you can sequence them and then
you would upload the raw data to
dovetail for for the next step we would
provide you recommendations on how many
repairs to what what coverage depth to
use on a particular library so we can
consult with the automat so that you
ensure that you get enough sequence
coverage
next is now that you have this tick
assembly what are the next steps for
your research oh that's a great question
so as Mark earlier set up I'm just I'm
going to start from the previous
question just add a little bit on the
challenges in getting a good assembly so
we work on non-model organisms and
normal organisms as you all might know
are not don't follow the same rules as a
model organisms most of the time and
that's a quite a big challenge so when
we started working on this genome
project decade ago we ended up having
this genome at least a genome of the
first tick any of the tick species so
far this is the only genome we had a
very fragmented genome but now with high
C thanks to dovetail with this new data
that we have a much better genome
assembly this gives us a quite this we
are very hopeful that we will be able to
improve it even further and we will we
already have a chromosome level assembly
now the next challenge for us is to
annotate this assembly or bring our
annotation to this assembly that will
help us correct our gene models because
most of our gene models right now with
their existing assembly are incorrect or
incomplete so this will allow us to
complete these gene models correct the
gene models and also we will be able to
now bring their transcriptome assemblies
to this genome assembly another really
good feature of chromosome level
assembly is we will be able to now see
make more physical mapping per se I'm
using it a little loosely but we will be
able to see how the genes are arranged
on the chromosomes and which genes make
a group so this essentially will be
improved quite a bit that I'm hoping so
yeah for next step for us is to to
annotate this new gene assembly with our
existing energy
and corrector gene models and completed
gene models make it a really good
assembly that can be used for by anybody
to do their transcriptome assembly to
single cell assemblies all these
different areas are now open for tech
researcher via in my lab we are focusing
on editing checks so we need to correct
gene models in order to make our guide
RNAs or CRISPR so this will also allow
us to to find the correct genes or
complete gene models to be able to do
the next steps so really this is going
to open a lot of doors not just for our
group but for the Petach community in
general we are already getting a lot of
requests to to publish this assembly so
the people can use it and we are in the
process with the vector base we will be
publishing it on vector-based so it's
open access everybody can use it so yeah
really and I think in short I can say
that this is going to push this big key
dick research in terms of genetics and
genomics forward and we are hoping to to
see more and more dick species sequenced
and assembled to chromosome levels thank
you um looks like this may be the last
question we have time for what coverage
of path bio do you suggest
yeah I'll take that one so PacBio is one
of the options for you know building the
initial draft assembly and if someone is
looking at using PacBio we we really
recommend around sixty x coverage to get
optimal results we have done a bit lower
50x coverage is probably acceptable but
anything below that we would probably
not want to attempt
thank you I would like to once again
thank dr. Monica gooey enough for her
presentation do you have any final
comments
ah gosh final comments I think I would
just like to say if you have a
fragmented assembly which is good enough
to to be able to do chromosome level
level assembly you might want to just
give it a try because this will change
the landscape completely once you have
the chromosome level assembly we are
very fortunate to to get this done
because they weren't really hopeful but
our assembly would work but we are very
pleased with the results
thank you I'd like to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration we would like to thank our
sponsor dovetail genomics for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through April 2019 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye
okay